Evaluation too can play a very important role in the iterative loops in
this analogical reasoning process. One can use several different methods for
doing evaluation. In the robot that can walk on water, for example, we can do
a simulation, or we can build a physical prototype. If the evolution succeeds,
then well and good, we can encapsulate the target polymer solution as a case and
store it in case memory. If the evaluation fails, we may need to
revisit transfer and see whether we want to transfer some of the knowledge or
revisit mapping, and perhaps align things differently or revisit retrieval and
perhaps try to retrieve a different source case. As an example,
supposing that the evaluation shows, then the robot that we designed for
walking on water is a little too heavy. In that particular case, we may
change the problem specification and retrieve a different kind of organism that
perhaps is a little lighter. Let us suppose that we evaluate the design of
the robot that can walk on water and find that the design is a little too heavy.
In that case, we can go back to the transfer stage and see whether we can
transfer some of the relationship that might make the robot a little lighter. Or
we can go back to the mapping stage and see whether we can align the source case
and the target problem slightly differently so that we can transfer a different
relationship. Or alternatively, we can go back to the retrieval state and try to
retrieve a source case, a different kind of biological organism altogether.
Thus, we see that the process of analogical reasoning is not linear at all and
see it can have many different kinds of iterations.
Analogical reasoning continues to be an important topic in our research and
biological-inspired design is becoming one.
We provide several readings with both topics in the class notes.